pas tout de suite accueillir nos
chroniqueurs et on va jouer à miss
tahiti douche c'est parti
[Musique]
vous allez voter pour savoir cris sera
officiellement miss tahiti douche ce
soir vous verrez et donc notre miss
prendra une douche
voilà une vraie douche vaudou stücke
t'inquiète pas l'anc et travail
s'inquiète pas de la kbc pour le choix
oui mais ne t'inquiète pas j'appelle
notre premier miss notre première miss
d'ailleurs ses premiers misson peux dire
un miss loire atlantique
il est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh lalala lalala alors déjà question
qu'est ce que c'est moche fois les miss
à pourquoi est ce que vous pouvez faire
parce que c'est il a le même visage
telenor alors non là là non pourquoi les
téléspectateurs de voter pour vous on
m'a déjà parce que je suis pas comme ça
depuis tout petit pain belge de miss
tahiti changent pas là pour enfiler les
perles moi je suis peut-être de nom déjà
non mais je vous dire déjà vous arrêtez
que mystery team parce que je suis fan
absolu j'ai vraiment voulu cette miss
france pour moi c'est là c'est le
meilleur coach et à meilleur coût
c'est le meilleur comme sur la meilleure
depuis très très longtemps
la dernière c'est delphine wespiser que
j'ai aimés comme sa bête noire
exceptionnel oui c'est vrai faux je
viens de nantes à la brigue la digue la
digue du cul je ressors tôt
je veux défendre toutes les fans je veux
défaire toutes les femmes je veux
défendre la cause d'aucune des femmes
révèle délicate est élégant ici il faut
poser ses couilles sur la table je le
fais mes choix
pourquoi j'ai démarré par vous qu'elle
vit chez ses americom en france salah au
bac ayons maintenant miss meurthe et
boulettes goulard martin goulet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mal ça lui va bien fondé ou faible
honda va bien et très belle en blanc va
parce que tu es là je te jure presse
sera donnée c'est vrai était très belle
on dirait entrée 10 e franchement à
malibu ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais non
mais elles valent benhaim elles sortent
des vannes de 1972 salle way allard
tamani betway arlette à malibu au la
lourdeur
bon alors pourquoi pourquoi les
téléspectateurs de voter attendez deux
minutes et six matches et on voit un
téton pas des masses a débuté la semaine
démarre très bien
alors oui alors l'aider les spectateurs
je fais pour miss boulette parce que je
suis plus tout jeune mais extrêmement
sympathique
oui et je sais que et dieu sait que dans
les vieux pots voilà est par ailleurs
bas dans toutes les régions gérées je
distribuerai de la poule est en fonction
d'accords merci à mon avis je suis pas
sûr que cette même prime c'est le merci
merci meurthe et couleur verte
[Applaudissements]
ouah n'est ce pas qu'alain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ses peurs
il fait ça fait peur d'entre eux armés
sont arrivés vraiment flipper les deux
sera gaulle et on les croise le soir à
bâle
non on ne peut pas on ne veut pas de ça
alors en autostop un blaise pascal un
beau jour et la beauté beauvau dirait on
dirait stéphane bern bicego qui sévit
dans louis xiv alors il ya une chose
dont je suis certain c'est que le hasard
n'existe pas la vie est faite de
rencontres et d'opportunités qu'il faut
savoir séduire ses dires c'est saisir
alors mais ces motifs le gars il
pennello soyons extraordinaire ensemble
le toc en binaire individuellement
ohlala qui a compris
[Applaudissements]
bravo on accueille as on accueille les
mecs comme toi mais c'est sa merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là franchement là très beau
concert très beau dos mairie body la
tête aussi mais on a vu que c'est çà et
là des clochers comme ça c'est pire que
le salariat des démos soit pourquoi les
gens doivent voter pour vous bonsoir je
suis christine kelly il faut voter pour
moi je fais ça parce que tout le temps
tu imites oui c'est comme jeter minutes
je vais vous dire pourquoi mais
premièrement parce que je suis très
choqué alors premièrement parce que je
pourrais vous donner tous les secrets du
cs à 8 deuxièmement parce que je doive
donner tous les secrets des chaînes info
ah oui et troisièmement parce que je
prenne ce sens menée en guadeloupe au
soler en parlant du csa c'est pas la fin
du mandat de l'ancien président dans un
mois dans un mois c'est la moins pire
ah ouais et beaucoup pen s'était
beaucoup de pannes qui s'en aille
voilà merci miss pyrénées
[Musique]
la date choisie et la direccte
en fait j'ai même en fait j'ai même pas
envie de vous écouter
je pense que les gens ne voteront pas
pour vous aident à nidau ça va ça va
très bien on voulait même pas changé de
voie c'est à dire on les jeux soient
sûrs que les français auront du pif et
que pour une fois on avait allez c'est
bon
pourquoi on doit voter pour vous en un
mot à ce que les français ne vont pas
voter uniquement pour un physique
ah oui ça l'est pas pas si tu vas passer
à miss pays de savoir où là
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
bien plus belle
elle est belle oui comme tout bon soir
bonsoir
pourquoi les gens doivent voter pour
vous mais ça sert ou abba malla si je
monte au nez vous savez moi je ne rejoue
pas faire mon discours oui merci je vais
faire un disco alors si le discours est
pourri sur la non et des gosses vous
rentrer directement chez vous ce soir je
vous le jure mais si je fais rangs des
jeunes alors est ce que vous voulez vous
mettre la barre vous ferez votre
histoire et votre discours est pourri je
vous le dis vous serez vous n'aurez pas
après la pub mais qui va décider qu'il
est pourri ce matin au nom sur les
téléspectateurs qui vont décider pas
trop leur demandera d'accord ok bah les
jeunes il a est très bas et toi qu'est
ce qu'un avantage c'est vrai que là
quand on la met à côté de l'autre c'est
sûr qu'elle est jolie
on est toujours mieux que le pire à
l'émission
[Musique]
elle est belle c'est ma préférée c'est
ma lady gaga tu viens de jazz de cully
c'est christine ça ça c'est kelly pas et
ça c'est christine kelly
ça c'est que ça soit une quasi ça c'est
pourquoi vous êtes les vous oserez vous
mes hommes cyril mais vous êtes jean
paul sort et vous vous êtes en
survêtement déçu si vous alliez se
retiennent le papillon non mais pas la
prochaine fois inquiétez pas je le
sortirai pour le prime de mercredi les a
dans le ventre déjà les papillons c'est
vrai que moi et me des papillons dans le
monde alors bon soir le public
bonsoir stéphane bon soit éric bonsoir
syrie comme disait albert camus maire
camille albert camus l'écrivain bien sûr
pas le pas le moba le basson voilà mal
luné mal nommer les choses c'est ajouter
au malheur du monde
alors si on met si je suis élue miss
france je serai le jeu j'oeuvrerai pour
le rayonnement de la langue française à
travers le monde et je vous promets que
race raidard cas entreront dans le vif
[Applaudissements]
on accueille on accueille miss le test
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'attends vos flatterie bien entendu qui
précisait alors salariale est là alors
déjà je vous dis vous êtes magnifique
d'issue à préserver
j'ai préféré je vous dirais mon
classement dans la tête
j'ai mon classement dans la tête et
sachez pack très hostile kouassi sachet
est lui non sachez que vous êtes dans
mon top 3 bien sûr non non non non non
je l ai dans mon top 3 harry les deux
autres je peux vous le dire et à
christine et ya géraldine ya pas qu il y
a pas moi j'aime qu'on avait les yeux
braqués lié avec cette coiffure et jeux
et vous mais vous vous êtes bien mais
vous vous préfère en nature est
légalement et vous vous risquez de
rentrer chez vous moi les gens nos
beautés ce beau vous voulez pompe
allongé français pendant vieux français
oui c'est pas parce que je couche avec
césar à miss luttait alors je suis il
faut voter pour moi forte pour moi parce
que je me suis tassé et donc on peut me
ranger n'importe où de face comme de
profil
je ne prends pas de place d'accords et
mon intérieur est très bien rangé
merci donc je peux courir dans tous les
cas et en plus je lutte pour l'argument
dans le monde et tout va lutter lui est
arrivé
sinon à gstaad solitude on a on aura
deux chroniqueurs qui ont mis au jour
dans un instant ils sont pas en valais
on va les emmener qui a déjà transmis
cela pour pouvoir choisir est on est on
est déjà en retard dans ma fête faites
votre fait votre discours je peux venir
à ce que vous êtes en train de dire
qu'est ce que je peux venir faire monter
score ici s'il vous plaît cyril hanouna
les avait vus la raison si je peux me
permettre je trouve que vous marchez pas
comme une miss quoi si vous pouvez
refaire l'arrivée parce que là c'était
n'importe quoi on aurait dit le plus
sorti d'un canon balesi manon mais pas
tous mamani
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que ça c'est grave
sa compatriote château culte alors on y
va alors j'aimerais je peux vous dire
que j'ai fait quinze ans de danse
classique ça m'a forgé un mental d'acier
pour affronter l'avenir
je pensais être une femme forte pour
vous soutenir et pour vous conseiller
dans tous les aléas de votre vie à part
ça j'adore la paix peace and love
d'autre part d'autres choses à dire si
vous voulez mais deux minutes il s'est
trompé de sam alors
[Applaudissements]
sinon alors c'est quoi la fin du 2 mai
sinon cela faisait près par les annonces
et on sait bien ce concept
alors pourquoi les gens doivent voter
pour vous mais d'un voté pour moi parce
que je pense être la bonne personne
voilà pour avoir fait autant de sport je
pense être assez fort dans mon mental
pour ceux se passe bien c'est moi tu du
pôle emploi aussi tu as si vous payez
j'aimerais dire aux producteurs des
marseillais de venir là là merci à lui
[Applaudissements]